Alexandra Ocasio Cortez accidentally
spills the beans we examine Tucker
Carlson's populism and the border wall
war continues this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh man so much to get to today Wow lotta
news breaking over the weekend plus plus
as you know later today if you are
subscribed over at daily wire then your
even get two extra hours of me every
single way it's gonna be unbelievable
you get to all of the news of the day
first we need to talk about how you send
your packages how you do your mail so I
know that you've been heading down to
the post office with this giant box of
stuff that you need to send off via the
post office and post office is great
don't get me wrong but you know it'd be
easier if you didn't have to do that if
you could just sit at your desk and make
sure that all of your mail goes out on
time with the proper postage well here's
the nice thing you can we do at the
daily wear offices I do from home using
stamps calm stamps calm brings all the
amazing services of the US Postal
Service directly to your computer
stamps.com is the faster more convenient
way to get postage simply use your
computer to print official US postage
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it and
the mail carrier just picks it up no
more lugging mail to the post office no
more hassles stamps com not only saves
you time it also saves you money as well
with stamps.com you get discounted
postage rates you can't even get at the
post office not to mention it is a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters there's no equipment at
least no long-term commitments again we
use it at the Daily wire offices it
saves us time it means you don't have to
wait in line means that we can do exact
pasta directly from our desks right now
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and the
digital scale start the new year off
right go to stamps comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
you can check it out there and type in
promo code Shapiro for that special
offer again stamps comm promote Shapiro
that gives you a four week trial plus
postage and the digital scale so a very
solid you okay so we begin today with a
reminder that the Democratic Party has
now taken over the house which means
that we have to take them seriously we
are now supposed to take all of their
policy prescriptions and all the things
they say seriously and which Democrats
should we take seriously well presumably
we should take seriously the Democrats
that the Democrats are taking seriously
you know the ones who are considered the
new leaders we should be taking we
should be taking serious stock of the
Democrats that the media say are the
ones we should be paying attention to
how do we know which ones well let's say
that there were a Democrat could been
ballyhooed as the new wave in the
Democratic Party a Democrat who'd been
featured on social media Democrat had
been featured by with profiles in van
fare in the New York Times in the
Washington Post a Democrat who was
featured on 60 minutes over the weekend
would it be fair to pay attention to
that person I think yes and I think that
if people said we shouldn't pay
attention to that person that that would
be a bit of media sophistry if the game
would be that Democrats pay attention to
a person and we're supposed to ignore
that person lest we be accused of being
obsessed with that person that would be
a bunch of crap right so the person of
whom I'm speaking of course is Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez now the reason that a lot
of folks on the right like to cover
Alexandra Ocasio cortez is because she
says dumb things a lot right sound she
says dumb things only sometimes she says
dumb things routinely like all the
things she says 90% of the things she
says are done the only thing she says
that are not done are things that are
pop culturally related so when Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez talks about like instant
pot recipes on instinct in in on
Instagram not so dumb when she talks
about how she's a pretty good dancer
not so dumb when she talks about
economics it's like she stuck her head
in an oven okay the things she says are
just idiotic and she gets caught out
saying idiotic things on a routine basis
but this does not seem to dim her appeal
any for Democrats which leads to an
ironic situation the same Democrats
who've accused Donald Trump of lowering
the standards of truth and fact the same
Democrats who say that Donald Trump lies
on routine basis about matters of policy
are worshipping at the altar of this
brash new persona
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez who is brash and
knew precisely because she won 12,000
votes in a Democratic primary in a
heavily blue district that is majority
minority and where the representative
happened to be a white person until
Alexandra o kasnia Cortez took over the
racial issue is only interesting insofar
as it had an impact on the voting
pattern in that primary okay the reason
that I bring this up is Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez was on 60 minutes last week she
proposed what she called a green new
deal the green New Deal would have
required within 12 years 100% of the
United States economy to be on renewable
energy sources right now only 17% of the
US economy is supported by renewable
energy sources so we're talking about
the cost of tens of trillions of dollars
at a minimum using the current
technologies that we have and if we
wanted to develop new technologies we
are probably talking about hundreds of
trillions of dollars in order to get to
a
completely green new deal she also
suggested that we should have racial and
gender based equity handled by the
Congress of the United States and that
we should raise the tax rates radically
so she did this interview on 60 minutes
because she is the new ideological
thought leader which makes sense I mean
we've already had the idiocy of watching
Bernie Sanders be the available
ideological thought leader for the
Democrats
we've already watched the Democrats
tried out a 70 in an ear octogenarian
socialist loon bag who's never passed a
single piece of decent legislation from
Vermont be the ideological thought
leader for the Democrats so why not
prettier dumber Bernie Sanders how about
that we can go with that right so 60
minutes brings out Ocasio cortez and she
says some things about policy so she
begins by pushing a 70 percent marginal
tax rate this is her big policy proposal
is that what we should do is we should
pay for her green New Deal which as I
say would cost tens of trillions of
dollars by you guessed it taxing rich
people more you have a progressive tax
rate system your tax rate you know let's
say from zero to $75,000 may have been
10% or 15% etc but once you get to like
the tippy tops found your ten millionth
dollar
sometimes you see tax rates as high as
60 or 70% it doesn't mean all 10 million
dollars are taxed at an extremely high
rate but it means that as you climb up
this ladder you should be contributing
more okay this is like watching my
four-year-old daughter explain basic
addition to me I mean that she has like
a certain amount of kind of baseline
understanding but she doesn't really get
it I like that Alexander Ocasio Cortes
is explaining to Anderson Cooper who I
promised you pays the top tart top
marginal tax rate she's explaining how
marginal tax bracket works to to
Anderson Cooper on national television
this is the new wave of the Democratic
Party you see like when you get to like
the very tippy top and the toppity
tiptoes and when you get to like the ten
million dollar that's taxed at a
different rate than like if you made $5
yes Alexandria we know and it's still
immoral to steal 70 percent of a dollar
that somebody makes for your own private
purposes also the notion that this is
going to pay for virtually anything is
nuts if she basically says okay if you
make over ten million dollars then we
should tax all of that at a seventy
percent rate and one of my favorite
things
about this is that people in the
Democratic Party are then repeating us
no it's it's not that bad like why would
that be so bad there's a thread on
Twitter this had 75 thousand retweets
from a person named Diana Anderson I
don't know who this person is this
person wrote okay so a lot of rich white
folks are freaking out about what a 70
percent tax rate on the wealthy would
look like and they're scared about it
and bleep even though it's literally
what rich Baby Boomers re dealt with
first of all rich baby boomers did not
deal with it they had massive tax
loopholes that were applicable during
the Eisenhower era when the top tax
bracket starting about 3.4 million
jointly for households was at ninety-one
percent the effective tax rate for those
households was about forty five percent
here's what this person says though they
say
post-world War two the tax rate peaked
at 94 percent on annual income over two
hundred thousand dollars this is post
World War two you will remember when we
were still paying off you know a massive
military spend by the way two hundred
thousand dollars in 1946 was like three
million bucks in 2018 in the decades
following and drop to a marginal tax
rate of seventy percent of all income
over two hundred thousand dollars
annually
yes and if you'll recall the 1970s
sucked economically before Ronald Reagan
massively caught the top marginal tax
rate and this person says let's take
let's take an example of what would
happen if we had a seventy percent
income tax rate for people making about
ten million dollars so let's say you're
Dwayne the rock Johnson you made sixty
five million dollars last year in one
year so that tell ten million dollar
cutoff is gonna hit you seventy percent
off everything above ten million dollars
that leaves you with sixteen point five
million dollars wow that's a big hit you
think on paper yeah that's a lot of
money to just give up in taxes no not
not on paper in reality giving up forty
five million dollars is a lot of money
to give up but this person says that
rate still leaves the rock with nearly
twenty million dollars considering his
ten million is also taxed at a lower
rate that's twenty million in net pay
for a year which is still a lot of money
so what's the rock whining about here's
why this is so intensely stupid the
reason that this is so intensely stupid
is because everyone will start using tax
avoidance strategies how do I know this
because France tried to do exactly this
hey a few years back let's go back in
the Wayback Machine - I like 2017 like
two years ago the Prime Minister of
France was a guy named Edouard Philippe
okay and he had to and he had tried to
impose he had tried to impose along with
Emmanuel macron economic reforms that
would have led to a massive wealth tax
and what happened all the millionaire's
left France in two thousand sixteen
twelve thousand millionaires immigrated
from France in 2015 ten thousand
millionaires left France it turns out
you know what rich people are really
good at picking up and moving it turns
out that rich people if you try to tax
them at a 70% rate above ten million
dollars you know they'll do they will
just sell their houses and leave and go
live in Monte Carlo if you think the
rock is sticking around to watch 40
million bucks of his disappear every
year so Alexandre Ocasio Cortez can pay
off her green Solyndra supporters you
are out of your damned mind you're crazy
it's not going to happen and even the
Washington Post basically acknowledges
this they do a full economic workup but
this is my favorite part I love this
this is what they say they say Ocasio
cortez his suggestion for nearly
doubling taxes on people earning more
than ten million dollars would bring in
seven hundred and twenty billion dollars
per decade seventy two billion dollars a
year except that except that that's not
what's going to happen here's it buried
deep in this article from The Washington
Post the real number is probably smaller
than that because wealthy Americans
would probably find ways around paying
this much higher tax ya think you think
maybe the rock just wouldn't do as many
movies I wouldn't work as hard
if I knew 70% of my money we're going to
the federal government already an
enormous amount of my money goes to the
federal government you think I would
take on extra jobs just so I could pay
the bills for the stupid ideas of our
Congress people there's something deeply
immoral about stealing seventy percent
of any dollar that anyone makes and if
you think that Alexander Ocasio Cortez
knows how to spend her money better than
the rock knows how to spend his money I
don't know what to tell you I'm with
cardi B I don't what the government does
with my bleeping money and neither do
you and the fact that the federal
government is now trying to seize that
money and people are cheering us on is
not so this is the new democratic push
is that they're going to massively raise
taxes yeah go with that I also love the
baseline lie that is being told here
which is that if you raise the top
marginal tax bracket seventy percent
that's gonna pay for everything you
crazy it ain't people in Denmark are
paying 60 percent of
income off the top in income tax if you
make about $60,000 a year you want to
pay for Bernie Sanders like programs you
can have Bernie Sanders like taxes and
those Bernie Sanders like taxes do not
look like a top tower a top marginal tax
bracket increase they look like a
massive middle class and lower class tax
increase because you must expand the tax
base if you do not expand the tax base
you are not going to take in more income
but that wasn't the dumbest thing of
kasnia courts head said she really
spilled the beans here no I'll explain
in just one second first let's talk
about how you can make your business
better so how can you make your business
better well you probably have a couple
of employees or you know low down on the
ladder or maybe you need somebody better
be not sure how to find them or maybe
you don't need to kick anybody up maybe
you just need better employees you're
expanding because the economy has been
good well zip recruit is the way for you
to get the best employees go to zip
recruit comm slash daily wire to hire
the right people
unlike other job sides if critter finds
qualified candidates for you it has
powerful matching technology they scan
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and then actively invite them
to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast
that's why zip recruiter is rated number
one by employers in the United States
that rating comes from hiring sites on
trust pilot with over a thousand reviews
right now my listeners can get zip
recruiter for free at zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire the process is really
easy the website is super usable and
again it helps you file out all of the
bad resumes so you're only looking at
the good ones if you love the show show
your support for the show and zip
recruiter by going to zip recruiter com
daily wired Dai ly WI re that's zip
recruiter comm slash daily Wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire which is why we use it a daily
wired go check it out zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire all right so that was
not the the dumbest thing Ocasio cortez
had to say but we're not supposed to
talk about the dumb thing she says again
because she's good at instagram and she
dances sometimes who so we can't talk
about that stuff let's talk instead
about how charming she is it's amazing
if you're a Democrat and you're charming
the merit dummy are the matter how many
stupid things you say if you're
Republican and you're dumb then matter
how charming you are and if you're
Republican who is both charming and
smart then we call you corrupt dan
Crenshaw I mean let's just take you you
want to see media bias in a nutshell Dan
Crenshaw is a war veteran who lost an
eye in combat his clever is witty
was great when he went on Saturday Night
Live has he received one 100th of the
media attention that this twenty
nine-year-old former bartender socialist
from New York is receiving like one iota
and Dan Crenshaw doesn't say dumb things
all the time and he actually has a
record of service and he happens to be
smart but you know if you're the media
then none of that matters right if
you're media the only thing that matters
is that she's a Democrat because she's a
Democrat we have to give her all sorts
of leeway and if you attack her if you
say that her ideas are bad then this is
because you are a sexist just the same
way that if you say Elizabeth Warren is
a charm was hack then this is because
you are also a sexist because if you
talk about likability but you're talking
about a Democrat this means that you're
a racist or a sexist or a bigot in some
way okay so the dumbest thing that
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez said was so dumb
on the 60 Minutes interview that even
Anderson Cooper looked at her and almost
vomited in her lap so Alexander Ocasio
Cortez was asked specifically about the
fact that she says a lot of things that
are not true that in common parlance she
lies a lot and she she will just trot
out arguments that make no sense she
will say things that are blatantly
factually false listen to her response
because it is telling about the way so
many folks on the political left think
about what politics is and it explains
why younger generation folks are turning
socialist what she's about to say is a
sign of deep immorality deep
philosophical immorality but she says it
was a straight face and so we take it
seriously I think there's a lot of
people more concerned about being
precisely factually and semantically
correct than about being morally right
but being factually correct is important
absolutely important and whenever I make
a mistake I say okay this was clumsy and
then I restate what my point was but
it's it's not the same thing as the
president lying about immigrants it's
not the same thing at all um yeah it is
so what she says there is that feelings
don't matter about your facts right my
slogan is facts don't care about your
feelings for her feelings don't care
about your facts so if she's morally
right she can lie she can get facts
wrong we shouldn't worry about her
being semantically or factually actor we
shouldn't worry about any of those
things accuracy is of no consequence
when what you're saying is morally right
so you might say that we should take her
seriously but not literally now I was
informed by Democrats that Donald Trump
had lowered the standards of the
presidency when it came to truth I was
informed by Democrats that Donald Trump
had destroyed our politics because he
says a lot of things that are factually
untrue and I've said in the past that
when Donald Trump says things that are
factually untrue that he should correct
them and that he's wrong and that
sometimes he's lying and that that's bad
but Democrats don't actually care about
all that what Democrats actually care
about is the narrative so Alexander
Ocasio Cortes when she says facts don't
actually matter what matters is being
morally right this shows why we are in
the state that we are she is not
actually saying anything different from
what Democrats have said for years for
literally my entire lifetime
hey Democrats have been saying my entire
lifetime that it is okay to lie so long
as you get to the end point that you are
seeking if you are Barack Obama you can
lie about liking your doctor and keeping
your doctor because the ends justify the
means
the ends are morally right therefore the
means not telling the truth to the
American people that's okay too
so when Ocasio courts head says I don't
have time to tell the truth people worry
too much about me being factually
accurate instead of morally right one of
the ways we decide whether you are
morally right is if you are factually
accurate it's pretty easy to tell if
somebody's lying all the time to you to
get you to do something pretty obvious
giveaway that what they are trying to
get you to do is probably not morally
right because the truth shall set us
free when we hear a group of facts that
are laid together to form an argument
then it is inherently more convincing
than a group of lies that are put
together to form an endpoint if we know
they are lies if you have to lie to get
somebody to identify with your
conclusion then you are not only doing
it wrong you're doing something immoral
itself there are certain cases in life
where lying is necessary there certainly
the Nazis at your door and you've got
somebody who's a resistor to the Nazis
hiding in your basement do you lie to
the not see the typical moral answer
would be yes although count would say no
that is not what we're talking about
here when we are talking about here is
basically lying to the American people
because you think that your point is
better than their point and this is what
the Democrats are
these days I don't like it when
Republicans do it I don't like when
Democrats do it I don't like it when
Donald Trump says things that are not
true about the economy or about
immigration or about the or about the
states of the Middle East I don't like
when he doesn't any of those things to
support his political viewpoint it's no
better when a Democrat does it but to
pretend that the standard has only been
lowered on one side as a joke the
standard has been lowered on both sides
for years and it was lowered by
Democrats a lot earlier than it was
lowered for Republicans she just let the
cat out of the bag so spare me your
lectures about Donald Trump undermining
American politics the same left that
disdains Donald Trump for his supposed
abolition of basic principles of the
presidency that same left cheers on
Alexandre Ocasio courts has every step
of the way that same left tells us that
Barack Obama never had a scandal that
same left says that Barack Obama had
never told the lie that same left says
that Bill Clinton should still be held
up as some sort of Halcyon of the
presidency and his wife should've won in
2016 I'm not gonna take moral guidance
from these folks just not gonna happen
and I'm certainly not gonna listen to
Democrats when they also claim that they
actually want to compromise that Donald
Trump is the one standing in the way of
compromise and this becomes particularly
galling when you're hearing it about the
wall so the Democrats are claiming now
they don't want to compromise but that
or that Donald Trump doesn't want to
compromise that they'd love to reach a
compromise but Trump won't compromise
again Ocasio Cortes she just says things
that are inadvertently true like
Democrats don't care about the truth and
also we'd like to tax the crap out of
you she also says Democrats have
compromised too much in past you can't
name a compromise like name a Democratic
compromise of the last say 15 years the
last time Republicans and Democrats
compromised on a bill honestly maybe
sequestration even that was not really a
compromise House like 2011 house 7 year
and eight years ago now but she says
Democrats have compromised too much and
there's something I think deeply telling
about the fact that she thinks the
Democrats have compromised too much when
she can't name a single Democratic
compromise in the last 10 years we as a
party have compromised too much and
we've lost too much of who we're
supposed to be in who we are
and the Democratic Party has lost I
think so I think I think we've
compromised things that we shouldn't
have compromised whether it's judgeships
with Mitch McConnell whether it's
compromising on climate change I think
we've there are some things that we've
compromised a little bit too much on ok
they've not compromised on judgeships
harry reid nuked the filibuster and
Mitch McConnell has rammed through
judges and on climate change Democrats
have not compromised when iota they just
haven't had the power to get through
their radical agenda so again just a
bunch of nonsense but it does
demonstrate with Democratic Party's head
is that they are radical they don't care
about truth when it comes to at least if
she's a representative of them I'm not
saying every Democrat there a lot of
Democrats out there I assume who are
still carrying about truth would still
like some compromise would still like
some moderation but not in the
leadership not in the leadership because
Pelosi can't step on Ocasio cortes
because she knows the passions with
Ocasio cortes in the same way that the
leadership couldn't step on Bernie
Sanders because they knew that the
passion was with Bernie Sanders so what
does this lead to well it leads to the
government shutdown that's happening
over the border wall so let's talk about
the latest on the border wall in just
one second first let's talk about how
you protect your property well the way
that you ought to protect your property
is with ring today over a million people
are using the amazing ring video
doorbell to help protect their homes
ring those home security begins at the
front door it does not end there so now
they're extending that same level of
security to the rest of your home with
the ring flood bike cam and just like
rings amazing video doorbell flood light
cam is a motion-activated camera and
floodlight it connects directly to your
phone with HD video and two-way audio
that lets you know the moment anyone
steps on your property you can see and
speak to visitors you can even set off
an alarm directly from your phone with
rings floodlight cam when things go bump
in the night you will immediately know
what it is whether you're home or away
the ring flood like cam lets you keep an
eye on your home from anywhere so go
check it out we have a ring floodlight
cam at our house or at least a rim video
doorbell at our house and it's great I'm
3,000 miles away but everybody thinks
that I'm home specifically because I can
pick up the ring and I can tell people
that I'm at home so nobody's robbing my
house ring floodlight cam offers the
ultimate in in home security with high
visibility flood lights and a powerful
HD camera that puts security in your
hands save up to 150 bucks off a ring of
security kit when you go to ring comm
/ban again that's ring comm / pen go
check it out right now ring calm / Ben
ring is well worth your time it's gonna
make your house safe or make you feel
from more secure
ring.com /ban okay so the Democratic
intransigence that has been pushed forth
by the Democratic base is exactly what I
predicted last year and when anybody
who's been watching the Democratic Party
predicted last year this is not a party
that was gonna come in and be reasonable
this was a party that was going to come
in and push the most radical agenda they
could and refused to compromise on
anything so Donald Trump has asked for
something like 5 billion dollars for a
border wall which let's face it would
not be sufficient to actually build the
border wall the actual cost of a border
wall apparently is between 11 and 13
billion dollars not five billion dollars
in any case five billion dollars is a
pittance compared to what we spend every
year on virtually everything else and we
do in fact have a border problem huge
numbers of people are coming across the
border in 2015 as according to the
Washington Post the year Donald Trump
launched his White House bid with a
promise to build a wall on the Mexico
border illegal migration to the United
States plunged 31% falling near its
lowest levels in 50 years in 2017
president Trump's first year in office
he continued to insist on the urgent
need for a border while even as illegal
crossings dropped even further with
parts of the federal government shutdown
over what is morphed into a defining
symbol of Trump's presidency
administration officials are clamoring
louder than ever only this time they
face a bona fide emergency on the border
this is according to the Washington Post
and not The Washington Times The
Washington Post and they're struggling
to make the case there's truly a problem
record numbers of migrant families are
streaming into the United States over
whelming border agents and leaving them
a holding leaving holding cells
dangerously overcrowded with children
many of whom are falling sick in a
letter to lawmakers on Friday the White
House and Department of Homeland
Security made a fresh appeal to amend
immigration laws they denounced as legal
loopholes and blame for creating a
border security and humanitarian crisis
but this is not going to happen so long
as Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats
refused to compromise now that
humanitarian crisis is not being created
only by the lack of a border wall it's
also being created by our immigration
procedures which require us to arrest
people and then people have to go to an
immigration court and while they're not
in an immigration court we either have
to imprison them or let them go
which would be catch and release all of
that is a mess and cleaning that up
should be top priority but Democrats are
not interested in cleaning up any of
this and they're particularly anti the
idea of a wall because they don't want
Trump to have a victory so you end up
with idiocies like this Nancy Pelosi
out front and center saying that the
wall itself is immoral
is what she said last week is an
immorality it's not who we are as a
nation and this is not a wall between
Mexico and the United States that the
president is creating here it's a wall
between reality and his constituents his
supporters what the hell does that mean
a wall between reality and his
supporters what how how do I love the
nobody in the media it's a scowl explain
and when she says this isn't a wall
between the u.s. and Mexico that is
literally what it is a wall between the
United States and Mexico some sort of
physical barrier that allows our Border
Patrol agents to know when people are
crossing illegally
why this is immoral in any way Democrats
have yet to explain I love that they can
just shout slogans like it's immoral and
it's not who we are
whenever a politician assures you it's
not who we are be aware that all they
are trying to do is shame you into not
asking the question why why is it not
who we are to protect our own border why
I will imagine there are certain things
that make us not who we are
right imprisoning children not who we
are because it's not who we are but
building a wall on the border that's not
who we are
president Trump responds by saying we
would like a steel barrier please this
isn't that true that tough you tweeted
out
VP Mike Pence and group had a productive
meeting with the Schumer Pelosi
representatives today many details of
border security were discussed we are
now planning a steel barrier rather than
concrete it is both stronger and less
obtrusive good solution and made in the
USA I don't know why Trump thinks this
comes across like a compromise obviously
it does not come across as a compromise
nonetheless he is trotting out members
of his administration to claim that it
is Mick Mulvaney who is his new chief of
staff was on Meet the Press and he said
that President Trump is compromising by
shifting from a wall to a fence which is
not actually a compromise but here he is
fences that we have built on the
southern border the ones who are already
there under Republican leadership
Democrat leadership there in San Diego
and El Paso more than 90% effective in
preventing criminal immigration we need
more of that do we need it from coast to
coast 2,000 miles all the way across
no and the president has admitted as
such there are places in the middle of
nowhere where technology will be better
but a barrier call it a wall call it a
fence the president actually said he
didn't care what you call it he even
offered to let the Democrats help him
design something he says as long as it's
a
effective he doesn't care what you call
it we made something to prevent people
from coming into this country illegally
then the president isn't wrong on this
and Mick Mulvaney is not wrong on this I
will say that the tactics that are being
used by both sides who are obviously
pander into their respective bases so
when it comes to the Democrats their
pans ring to their base by saying we
don't need a barrier of any kind that
walls themselves are an imposition oh
it's so terrible Eric's wha well who
wants to run for president for some odd
reason he tweeted out that a wall
separates us and them right like
citizens and people trying to get in
illegally correct
Eric swallow and he said that's not who
we are in the u.s. literally that's how
you define a nation is by separating us
from them that doesn't mean that them
are bad but it doesn't mean that you
have to separate populations otherwise
you don't know who's a citizen and who
is not a citizen so Democrats are
pandering to their most radical base and
then President Trump is pandering to his
base in the sense that he should have
done this immediately upon entering
office he had a Republican Congress he
had a Republican Senate holding his own
Senate's feet to the fire would have
been a better move than trying to hold
Nancy Pelosi's feet to the fire now
President Trump is supposedly
considering using emergency powers to
build the wall according to CNN on
Friday President Trump said he was
considering using emergency powers which
would allow him to use military funding
to build a wall on the us-mexico border
he said I can do it if I want he said we
can call the national emergency because
of the security I haven't done it I made
it but we can call the national
emergency and build it very quickly so
presumably he'd be talking about
invoking two separate laws one is ten US
Code section 284 support for counterdrug
activities and activities to counter
transnational organized crime that
provision says that the Secretary of
Defense may provide support for the
counselor drug activities or activities
to counter transnational organized crime
of any department or agency of the
federal government if such support is
requested by the official responsible
for the counter drug activities or by
the appropriate state officials and this
could amount to the maintenance and
repair of equipment that has been used
to stop such drug-related activity so
it's never been invoked in this way that
you have somebody on the border and then
they say to the president we need border
wall please misdirect funding from other
Department of Defense priorities to the
wall because of counter drug activity
also it would be kind of a stretch to
suggest that this would fall under May
or repair or upgrading of equipment that
usually amounts to you know making the
equipment better not building an
entirely new barrier that spans
thousands of miles of United States
border legally speaking would be
difficult for the president to do this
nor really should he because we don't
want the president routinely using
national emergency powers to do stuff he
can't otherwise get congressional
approval for ten US Code 2808 is the
other one that he theoretically could
use this is construction Authority in
the event of a declaration of war or
national emergency this is what he's
talking about with the national
emergency under this provision of US law
in the event of a declaration of war or
the declaration by the president of a
national emergency in accordance with
the national emergencies act that
requires the use of the Armed Forces the
Secretary of Defense without regard to
any other provision of law may undertake
military construction projects this has
only been used in the aftermath of 9/11
to build up military bases in certain
areas and it's supposed to be an
emergency use right it's supposed to be
the Congress just hasn't had time to
consider the reprioritization of Defense
funding it is not really supposed to be
a way of overruling Congress when
Congress doesn't want to do something
listen again I'm in favor of the wall
I'm in favor of Trump putting pressure
on Congress over the wall I'm in favor
of Trump saying that he's happy to shut
down the governor I don't really care
about any of that what I do care about
is you don't get to expand the national
emergency powers of the executive branch
without understanding that Democrats
will do exactly the same thing the other
way wait until the shoes on the other
foot and Democrats declare that they are
going to have to build out some sort of
facility that you don't want them to
build out some national surveillance
build out because Congress won't give
them what they want and it's a national
emergency wait until they do that
expanding the powers of the presidency
is never a good idea even when you think
that the president is somebody of your
party who's doing something that you
like this would be struck down in court
and it would it should be struck down in
court now in just a second I want to
talk about an ideological rift that's
broken out inside the Republican Party
that I think is really deeply deeply
important it's because of a monologue
Tucker Carlson gave that brings brings
it up
I don't get to the site everything maybe
the most important thing that we talked
about today but first let's talk about
your investment strategy so you don't
know all that much about investment
right I mean you're kind of a newbie to
the market and you've never really tried
investing before well the best way to
try investing is to start investing and
the best way to start investing is by
using the Robin Hood
why because Robin Hood is investing app
that lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options encrypt those all
commission-free folks in my office are
using Robin Hood all the time they've
shown me the app it is clear it is
beautiful it is easy to use you can make
a trade with like three clicks and they
have a no Commission fee structure which
means that while other brokerages charge
up to ten bucks for every trade which
could be cutting out your entire profit
margin depending on how much you're
trading Robin Hood doesn't charge
commission fees you trade stocks and you
keep all your profits they have
easy-to-understand charts market data
you place a trade in just four taps on
your smartphone
Robin Hood webs flat there there Robin
Hood web platform also lets you view
stock collections like a hundred most
popular entertainment social media and
you can learn how to invest as you build
your portfolio discover new stocks track
your favorite companies Robin Hood is
giving my listeners a free stock like
Apple for Sprint's help build your
portfolio today sign up at Shapiro Robin
Hood calm that Shapiro dot Robin Hood
not come again I've looked at the app it
is beautifully designed I mean really
clear really easy and folks in my office
are using it to learn how to trade
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm go check it
out right now Shapiro dot Robin Hood
Khanna get that special deal of free
stock like Apple Ford or Sprint's help
build your portfolio okay I want to get
to what I think is actually the most
important section of today's show which
is Tucker Carlson's take on populism and
the the debate that's now broken out on
the right over the role of government in
American life and in the economy but
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire calm and subscribe so today
it begins starting today the Ben Shapiro
show is rolling out two more hours of me
okay you can listen live on radio in a
bunch of markets across the country but
only subscribers will be able to get the
full three hour show on demand meaning
my podcast and the two additional hours
we're doing a little bit later this
afternoon so make sure to subscribe to
daily wire.com right now it's just $9.99
a month means you get all the old
episodes and it means you get all the
new episodes like you really will not be
able to get this stuff reg even if
you're in a big talk radio market where
my show is broadcast you're not gonna be
in car all two hours then it's broadcast
live plus the first hour which is the
podcast where you're not gonna get all
three hours in the car unless you're a
truck driver or something which is great
but most people are not gonna be able to
do that and that means they're really
what you ought to be doing is going and
subscribing so you can get all the hours
on demand whenever you want them and you
can see the clips and we're gonna be
doing a thing as the time rolls forward
where we take your subscriber questions
during some of the breaks it's gonna be
a blast we
all sorts of new goodies coming up for
you this year that's $9.99 a month I
mean we are slaving out here for you
people all you have to do is subscribe
go check it out I mean Senya is getting
up at like 4 o'clock in the morning my
producer to make sure that you have the
content that you need the least you can
do is pay for her coffee she's a
charming person I promise you send he's
a wonderful person how dare you sir not
pay for her cloud in any case $99 a year
gets you all of those Afra mentioned
flurries Plus this the very greatest and
all beverage vessels view it feast your
eyes upon it
the leftist tiers hot or cold tumbler
magnificence bottled and sold to you at
that low low annual price $99 a year
also please subscribe to us over at
youtube / itunes we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so one of the things I love talking
about on the show is obviously
conservative philosophy and ideology now
the things that are really important
that we like to discuss because well the
left is a real threat there is also a
serious debate that is broken out inside
the right over the role of the free
market now I know that a lot of folks
who are kind of older conservatives
Reagan conservatives they're not
necessarily aware that this debate has
broken up because it's been glossed over
by a lot of politicians a lot of
politicians say things like I love the
free market by well once you add that
but to the end of I love the free market
what you're really talking about is
government intervention ISM in the
market the person who made I think the
best case for such interventionism made
that case last week he gave him analog
on his Fox News show Tucker Carlson it
was about a 15-minute monologue
regarding the future of economics and
politics in the United States now I've
interviewed Tucker Carlson we did a
Sunday special on my podcast with Tucker
where we discussed a lot of these issues
I really think the Tucker is wrong on a
lot of this but I think that the
economic populism he's espousing is
becoming increasingly popular in a
Republican Party that has forgotten a
lot of its free-market capitalist accrue
to and is ignoring the benefits of the
free market in favor of government
intervention ISM I think they're looking
for fixes in the wrong places I think
what ails America right now is a crisis
of soul
what ails America right now is a hole in
the American heart a hole that used to
be filled by community and social fabric
and religion and that has fallen apart
and now people are seeking to fill that
hole with economic solutions in the same
way that some folks on the Left seek to
fill that hole in the American heart
with economic solutions they attribute
the problems in America to bad policy
and there's truth to the idea that the
American government has pursued bad
policy but I would say that bad policy
is largely welfare based Tucker and a
lot of members of the Republican Party
are now claiming that the bad policy is
trade based for example that we need
tariffs or that it is a failure of
redistribution ISM that we need higher
taxes or these are cases being made by
actual populace inside the Republican
coalition so I think that the strongest
possible case for this was made by
Tucker over over the last week and he
basically argues that the social
breakdown that we are seeing is a result
of government non interventionist we
actually need more government in our
lives so here is what Tucker here here's
how Tucker let off his monologue
what kind of country will it be then how
do we want our grandchildren to live
those are the only questions that matter
the answer to them used to be obvious
the overriding goal for America is more
prosperity meaning cheaper consumer
goods but is that still true does anyone
still believe that cheaper iPhones or
more Amazon deliveries of plastic
garbage from China are gonna make us
happy they haven't so far a lot of
Americans are drowning in stuff and yet
drug addiction and suicide are
depopulating large parts of the country
anyone who thinks the health of a nation
can be summed up in GDP is an idiot okay
the health of a nation cannot be summed
up in GDP I don't know a single
Republican conservative who believes
that the health of a nation overall can
be summed up in GDP and I have decried
the breakdown of our social fabric at a
time when we are freer and more
prosperous than we have ever been and
that that breakdown though is not
attributable Tekin omits and here's
where Tucker goes wrong okay so what
Tucker says is our GDP has gone up and
there's a life expectancy in the last
couple years has gone down obviously
that's an economic problem I would say
no what we've seen over the past two
centuries is a massive rise in life
expectancy a massive decline in child
mortality our children are alive and our
parents are alive because of the rise of
free markets and capitalism and
innovation and entrepreneurship low
taxes less government regulation all of
that has led to the prosperity we enjoy
if we are blowing that that is our own
fault that doesn't have to do with our
capacity to get those cheap products he
can decry cheap products from Amazon as
much as he wants but you have a nicer
phone you have a nicer car you have a
nicer house you have a nicer table you
have a nice for microwave you have a
nice a refrigerator you have all those
things because of the free market now
nobody said that that stuff was going to
make you happy but to conflate the two
problems is though the nicer of a
refrigerator is what has made you
unhappy is a huge mistake and it's a
mistake made by people who are on the
left and also on the right so what I
would say is yes all this stuff has made
us more prosperous it hasn't necessarily
made us more happy I don't know a single
religious person who's ever made in
opposite contention by the way Moses
says this Jesus says this every major
prophet of the Old Testament says this
that stuff isn't going to make you happy
the Beatles said it right there's
nothing to make you happy but Tucker
seems to think that if you redistribute
the stuff then that may make you more
happy so Tucker goes
and he says that what we really need is
an economy that is structured for us the
people now this sounds a lot more like
Bernie Sanders than it does like Ronald
Reagan and this is happening inside the
Republican Party
so here is what Tucker had to say for
America is both simpler and more elusive
than mere prosperity it's happiness
there are a lot of agree ingredients in
being happy dignity purpose self-control
independence above all deep
relationships with other people those
are the things that you want for your
children
they're what our leaders should want for
us and would want if they care so I
agree that our leaders don't want enough
social fabric for us but again this is
not an economic problem and when Tucker
says this is an economic problem he's
got a problem himself when he says that
the goal in America is happiness no the
goal in America is pursuit of happiness
if you fail to pursue happiness properly
that is your fault freedom is about
getting everyone out of the way and then
it's your job to pursue happiness which
the founders saw as an actual goal
happiness was not just like what you
want to do today happiness was pursuing
virtue in accordance with reason that's
what happiness was to the founders and
so the idea was government was gonna get
in your way get government out of your
way and now it's your job to pursue
happiness and a free economy allows you
to alienate your labor and to act like a
free person in doing so right all of
that is good and necessary and vital but
the economy and your spiritual existence
are two different things
so the second I wanna get to more from
Tucker on this because I think that he's
he's not wrong when he points out that
we have a soul problem in the United
States he's wrongly says we can fill
that soul problem with an economics
solution when he says that we want
dignity and purpose and self-control
independence for our children that's
true but that's not a problem that can
be solved by simply slapping a tariff on
China
these are prot as a parent these are
problems that are solved by you talking
to your children about values and
morality and decency that's where the
lack comes in 17 year-olds we're not
committing suicide because pops didn't
because his pops lost his job at the
factory in 1994 17 year-olds are
committing suicide because their parents
got divorced 17-year olds are committing
suicide because they live in a world
without values without social fabric and
without guidance that's why 17 year-olds
are killing themselves that's why the
opioid epidemic is happening it's
happening because yes there were markets
created for addictive substances and
that's a place
we can talk about how the market has
failed but that's not really what
Tucker's talking about what he's talking
about is the idea that an economy ought
to be chained up and it ought to work
for us except you can't enslave an
economy anymore than you can properly
enslave a person nor should you
freedom matters so Tucker continues by
saying that the big problem here is not
is not that we don't know what to do
it's that our leaders just don't care
about us and this I objected I think
that our leaders do care about us I just
think they suck at their jobs
I think they care about pandering toss
for votes I think maybe what we ought to
have is a leadership class that is more
concerned with doing right then is
concerned with pleasing its own
population Edmund Burke talked about
this a lot the British statesman he
suggested that being a representative of
your public didn't just mean channeling
what your public wants at any given
moment it also meant sometimes standing
up to that public and saying that what's
best for them is not necessarily what
they think it is maybe what's best for
them is freedom being an elitist is it
so funny Tucker rails against the elites
i rail against Ely tests I think people
who think they can control your life are
the people who are wrong Tucker seems to
think that the people who control your
life ought to simply take control of the
the ring that is the government like the
j.r.r tolkien ring that is the
government and use it on behalf of you
my view is that that is an elitist point
of view
nobody should control that ring because
that ring does not belong to anyone
right the market is something we hold in
common our society is something we hold
in common you don't get to seize the
power from that society and then
administer it top-down for the benefit
of any particular group no matter how
much that group happens to be suffering
they say here's Tucker though making
this case what our leaders don't care we
are ruled by mercenaries who feel no
long-term obligation to the people they
rule one of the biggest lies our leaders
tell us is that you can separate
economics from everything else that
matters
economics is a topic for public debate
family and faith and culture meanwhile
those are personal matters both parties
believe this that is not true at all
okay the Democratic Party does not
actually believe that economics is a
topic for public debate but family faith
and culture are personal matters that's
non c'est parti in this monologue
functionally libertarian how
disconnected you have to be to believe
that the Democratic Party is
functionally libertarian they want
control every aspect of your life but
they are functionally libertarian it's
because Tucker and a lot of populous are
trying to create a third wave right a
new wave of people who are not
Republicans and not Democrats they're
populist except it turns out that both
if there is some sort of consensus it is
from a Democratic Party and the
Republican Party that they also control
too much of your life not that they
agree that we shouldn't control any of
your life but that they ought to control
too much of your life and restructure
the economy to their liking right
Tucker makes the case that social
conservatives have blown it why because
he says the market forces have destroyed
the family it's again this is Tucker
railing against the free market this is
happening inside the conservative
movement now I like and respect Tucker a
lot I think Tucker is a smart guy I
think he's really talented but I think
that this is dangerous stuff from a
conservative point of view
Tucker suggests that families are being
crushed by market forces here's what he
has to say that families are being
crushed by market forces never seems to
occur to them they refuse to consider it
questioning markets feels like apostasy
both sides in this missed the obvious
point culture and economics are
acceptable in separably intertwined
certain economic systems allow families
to thrive you know which economic
systems allow families to drive the same
economic systems that allow individuals
to thrive free markets allow families to
thrive socialist countries do not have
solid families communist countries do
not have solid families when the
government becomes your family your
family falls apart if you believe that
capitalism has undermined the free
market I mean it has undermined the
family what I would suggest is that
cultural forces have undermined the
family at the same time that capitalism
has eliminated poverty globally again
that's our fault cultural forces and
economic forces may be intertwined but
not so much so that process that added
prosperity means that families are
falling apart so how exactly does Tucker
make that case so I would make the case
that the economic forces that have led
to the decline of families now largely
lie in the welfare state so the welfare
state that has convinced people that
they don't need to stay with their
partner when raising a child right that
has destroyed the family and you can see
the statistics in 1960 basically the the
white legitimacy rate to make this a non
racial issue the white illegitimate rate
was near zero
today it's 36 percent and then that
it happen because of simple freedom in
the in the free market that happens
because people have been incentivized
not to stick around with their kids and
with their wives and wives have been and
women have been incentivized not to
stick around with their husbands Tucker
basically proclaims that the free
markets have led to the decline of
family he says that male wages declined
because manufacturing has declined first
of all it's not factually true
manufacturing has not disappeared it's
remarkably stable the rest of our
economy has grown manufacturing
represents less of a percentage of our
overall economy than it did 50 years ago
but it represents exactly the same
amount of productivity that it did 50
years ago the middle class in the United
States is not disappearing and then he
suggests that women are making too much
money and that's why they're not getting
married which again is count contrary to
what's actually happening the women who
are not getting married are not women
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
and then having a baby out of wedlock
right the women who are not getting
married
are the women who are making twenty
thousand dollars a year and don't have a
marriage Abul husband and are getting
knocked up I mean that's that's where
single motherhood is coming from now the
the real problem that I have where it
finally comes down is that Tucker
basically suggests that we have a rich
class in the United States of elites who
are not helping out the poor class in
the United States enough and they ought
to be doing so with money my contention
is that this is not a money problem
this is not a money problem there are
plenty of market failures there are
plenty of problems with the market and
we can talk about those but to pretend
that capitalism and market capitalism
he says market capitalism is a tool like
a staple gun or a toaster no market
capitalism is a representation of our
deepest values a value that suggests
that we are free individuals with the
capacity to alienate our own labor labor
to contract with each other to to make
deals with each other to make free
choices in our own life market
capitalism is not one choice among many
it is the only free choice in a in a
land of tyranny market capitalism isn't
the problem here the problem is a
problem of the human soul and the
breakdown of the social institutions
that inculcated virtue and that virtue
was necessary to upholding a stable
free-market in which people could live
together in peace and solidarity okay
with all that said time for some things
that I like and then some things that I
hate so things that I like today so over
the weekend I went I saw Aquaman now I
know everyone thinks I'm a DC partisan
because I am a DC partisan but hey I'll
say it I thought Justice League was
abysmal right
at the time I thought Justice League
stunk and when I saw the preview for
Aquaman I know to think I mean it'll
look kind of cheesy and it is and it's
great
okay Aquaman then first of all the
special effects are better than anything
you've seen in a Marvel movie in the
recent past at all I mean the special
effects in this movie are actually
first-rate they're a couple of scenes
that just look great and Jason mamoa who
plays Aquaman it's not that he's a great
actor but he plays Jason Momoa and it
turns out Jason Momoa is really good at
playing Jason Momoa Aquaman is basically
a dude bro and it's kind of great it's
kind of fun okay so here's a little bit
of the preview which doesn't do justice
to the actual movie which is raking in
the money as well it should because it's
a pretty good movie and it's certainly a
lot of fun to watch and look at here's a
little bit of the preview my father was
a lighthouse keeper
my mother was a queen but life is a way
of bringing people together could unite
our words one day check it out
author is talking to the fish
they made me what I am okay so it's kind
of great and Jason Momoa is kind of
great and there's some really terrific
action set-pieces what's amazing about
the DC Universe is that they really blew
it and how they rolled this thing out so
in their old that Man of Steel which is
the Superman movie and then they did not
do a standalone Batman movie and then
they did not - a standalone Wonder Woman
movie and then they did not - a
standalone Aquaman or cyborg movie
instead they rolled out Justice League
right they did bad they did Man of Steel
and then they did Batman V Superman and
then they did Justice League like all of
these right back to back I think they
did Wonder Woman right before Justice
League actually what you have to do is
what Marvel did right you bring out each
of these heroes individually in their
own movie and then you have the
crossover so they blew that but anybody
who says the DC Universe is dead Wonder
Woman is a standalone franchise and
that's making all sorts of money Aquaman
is now standalone franchise this movie
is going to make more money than Wonder
Woman by leaps and bounds it's made a
bunch a bunch of money because it's a
pretty good movie so that means Aquaman
is alive and it means that Wonder Woman
is alive it means you need to recast
Superman it means you need to recast
Batman it means that you need to do a
cyborg movie that's actually pretty good
and then it means that you need to do
another crossover movie and basically
act like Justice League didn't exist
that's that's that's what has to happen
in the DC Universe but the DC Universe
is very much alive and kicking and good
for the people who put together Aquaman
which is a fun movie okay other things
that I like today so there is a rule in
politics that there are certain things
that you're not allowed to say that you
just can't say one of the things you are
not allowed to say and you're not
allowed to talk about is what they call
rapid onset gender dysphoria so we
talked about this a few months back
there was an abstract from Brown
University that specifically talked
about how basically gender dysphoria was
being treated like cutting or like
bulimia or anorexia that was becoming a
trendy thing among certain groups of
particularly young women and then people
were sort of doing it in groups that
people who are surrounded by folks who
considered themselves transgender were
more likely to start considering
themselves transgender abigail Schreyer
has a very very gutsy column in today's
Wall Street Journal talking about all of
this saying like other social contagions
such as cutting and bulimia rapid onset
gender dysphoria overwhelmingly afflicts
girls but unlike other conditions this
one though not necessarily it sufferers
gets full support from the medical
community the standard for dealing with
teens who assert they are transgender
affirmative care immediately granting
the patient's stated identity there are
to be sure a few dissenters this idea of
what we're supposed to do his therapist
is to affirm that's not my job says like
psychotherapist Lisa Marciano if I work
with somebody who's really suicidal
because his wife left him I don't call
his wife up and say hey you got to come
back we don't treat suicide by giving
people exactly what they want but giving
in to patients demands is exactly what
most medical professionals do go and
face with our OGD like fashionable and
tragic misdiagnosis of the past this one
comes with irreversible physical trauma
and this this column is a gutsy column
talking about something you're not
supposed to talk about which is the fact
that rapid onset gender dysphoria is a
thing that it is not a reflection of a
deep-seated biological need to change
your gender that the treatment for it is
not always effective and that maybe we
ought to consider more seriously before
we go along with the it's time to
mutilate your body because you said six
months ago and discovered six months ago
that you're a member of the opposite
gender because you went to a gender
studies course at Brown but it's a
pretty gutsy column you should go check
it out in today's Wall Street Journal ok
time for a couple of quick things that I
hate so the Golden Globes were last
night they were predictably terrible the
the Golden Globes I don't even know why
anyone pays attention to this the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association
which is like seven guys who are really
old from places we don't care about and
they gave the top musical or drama or
Musical or Comedy Award to the to the
Queen movie which a parent's about human
Rhapsody which apparently wasn't even
very good and then they gave the and
then they gave the Best Drama Awards who
I believe Green Book correct which is a
from from by all accounts rather
mediocre like it's okay
but it's nothing special not a shock
they're also not a shock when a bunch of
people got up and made leftist messaging
points because this is what we do now so
here was Christian Bale
Christian Bale won a Best Actor in a in
a comedy award for vice because we have
to give a lots of awards to a movie that
no one has ever seen or will see vice up
a movie about Dick Cheney apparently
scrawled by crayon and scrawled ink ran
by Adam McKay Christian Bale gets up and
and credits Satan for his inspiration in
playing Dick Cheney he should know since
he allegedly had a physical altercation
with his own mother and was screaming at
the lights the lights people famously on
set
Christian Bale famous
crazy person talking about how Satan was
his inspiration for for Dick Cheney
thank you to that geezer over there Adam
he said he said instead I've got to find
somebody who can who can be absolutely
charisma free and reviled by everybody
so he went a Scobie bail what do you
think Mitch McConnell next that could be
good then it
thank you to Satan for giving me
inspiration on how to play this role
okay so he's the second promise of
prominent leftist after Saul Alinsky to
thank Satan for his inspiration but it
is amazing how everybody claps and
cheers in Hollywood for all this sort of
stuff do you think anybody in Hollywood
ever have the balls to do a movie like
this about Hillary Clinton who actually
is extraordinarily parodic 'el like you
can just do a parody of her full time of
course not the best part of this Golden
Globes by the way was the opening
monologue where Andy Samberg along with
Sandra oh is that who that is she is so
the the two of them did a monologue in
which they made no jokes because this is
what they have been relegated to what's
funny about this is that everybody gets
the joke but nobody's willing to say
that the joke is that everyone in
Hollywood is a nasty nasty horrible
human being who will destroy somebody's
career on a whim here is the opening
monologue where they deliberately make
no jokes without mentioning that the
real reason they're making no jokes is
because everyone is scared crapless in
hollywood of having their career
destroyed like Kevin Hart has he had his
career destroyed awards and one lucky
audience member will host the Oscars
now some of you may be wondering why the
two of us are hosting together and the
reason is we're the only two people left
in Hollywood who haven't gotten in
trouble for saying something offensive
Oh Sandra that reminds me you know what
race that people really gets under my
skin Andy the Hollywood half marathon
because it messes up all the traffic you
know oh yeah I hate that race of people
it's the worst race of people okay so
again this is what humor has been
relegated to and they don't even get
that
this is what they've done right this is
what Hollywood has done they're laughing
at their own inability to laugh at
things so well done Hollywood just
really really expert stuff right there
okay final point in the things that I
hate today so I want to mention this
last week I had a meeting with some
folks at a charity and I want to mention
which charity because it's really not
relevant was nonpartisan charity with
involved in a cause that is supremely
nonpartisan it was a charity in the arts
right and they were looking for a board
member and I was seriously considering
joining the board of this of this
charity because why the hell not and
then it occurred to me I mean I warned
them look I'm political which means that
probably there will be other people on
the board who don't like what I have to
say but who cares I don't like what they
have to say we're all here to help out
people in the arts and one of the board
members said well there may come a point
where there's a bunch of resistance to
you and we have to throw you off the
board and it occurred to me that we now
live in a reality so nasty and terrible
that if you are of the right wing you
cannot actually be on a nonpartisan
board helping people in completely
nonpartisan ways and completely anodyne
ways out of fear that somebody will
target you and other members of the left
we're on the nonpartisan board we'll see
fit to destroy your life for having
tried to do something charitable that's
where we are well the same thing is true
in comedy the same thing is true in
Hollywood it's true across the board
it's really nasty and it's really ugly
if we can't get together on nonpartisan
boards even do good things out of fear
that someday somebody is gonna come down
on one of the members of the board and
the other members of the board will see
fit to destroy that person who is just
they're trying to do a good thing I
don't know how we're gonna get along I
mean you want to talk about the
breakdown of the social fabric that has
nothing to do with economics and
everything to do with values principles
and decency all of which seem to have
fled via the back door all right well we
will be back here a little bit later
today so go check it out over at daily
wire.com i'm ben shapiro
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Alex and Garo Audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing